AHHHH
haha just kidding
Hey everyone, Julia here for DNews
Losing a limb is never something to laugh
at.
While humans can build awesome robotic arms,
other animals have their handy own way of
dealing with the problem.
Like the moon jellyfish.
If this ocean invertebrate loses a limb it
simply moves around the other remaining limbs.
In a recent study published in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences found
that the jellyfish restore functionality in
a process the researchers call symmetrization.
The jellyfish have to be perfectly symmetrical
in order to swim properly.
If they can’t swim to find food or swim
away from a predator, well they’ll be swimming
with the fishes.
Or… they’ll you know get eaten or something.
The researchers found that the jellyfish pull
off this game of musical arms by using their
muscles to push apart the arms as widely as
possible.
And the whole process is fast, like anywhere
from 12 hours to 4 days.
While the moon jellyfish use symmetrization
to compensate for losing a limb or two, other
animals simply regrow their missing body parts.
Most of us know that the starfish, excuse
me sea stars, can regrow their arms and in
some species, they can regrow entire bodies
out of limbs.
But there’s tons of other animals out there
who can regrow limbs too.
Like Salamanders, Zebrafish and even some
insects like cockroaches.
But sometimes limbs aren’t always perfect
copies of the original.
Like regrown tadpole tails are missing a few
nerves.
But some animals go one step further, some
animals can perfectly regrow their heads.
One small animal, Hydractinia, is a head above
the rest.
Commonly called “snail fur” because it
grows on the shells of snails and crabs, this
tiny animal can regrow its entire head if
it gets bitten off by a hungry predator.
But they aren’t alone in this remarkable
ability.
Planaria also have amazing abilities to regrow
themselves.
Literally, they can reproduce asexually and
just make more copies of themselves.
And these guys can also regrow their heads.
But what’s weird is, in one study published
in the Journal of Experimental Biology, researchers
found that worms with regrown heads had the
same memories as before.
How?
Well the researchers aren’t so sure, but
think that maybe their memories get stored
in other cells in the body and then get imprinted
into the new brain when it grows.
But what makes these animal’s powers of
regeneration so good?
In short, stem cells.
Stem cells are undifferentiated cells which
have the ability to grow into any type of
cell or tissue.
All animals have these, I mean we grow body
parts from scratch as an embryo.
But most mammals lose their pluripotent stem
cells, or stem cells that are general but
can grow into more specific cells later.
Some animals like Hydractinia and Planaria
use pluripotent stem cells to regenerate themselves.
Hydractinia keep their embryonic stem cells
for their whole lives.
Whenever their heads get eaten up, stem cells
flood the neck area and start to build a new
head.
But other animals have different cellular
mechanisms.
In salamanders, their limbs regenerate from
adult tissue cells.
Basically the cells dedifferentiate and form
a mass called a blastema.
And from this structure, the cells differentiate
again and can regrow an arm or a leg.
This whole process can take anywhere from
a month to three months depending on how old
the animal is.
But what’s interesting is that some researchers
like David M. Gardiner, a professor of developmental
and cell biology at the University of California-Irvine,
think that all animals might have the ability
to grow body parts of pluripotent cells.
That some common ancestor that even we share
with something like the snail fur was able
to keep its stem cells well into adulthood.
For some reason ours is just turned off, but
he thinks one day we’ll find the on switch.
Speaking of animals remarkable ability to
regenerate, there might an animal that can
live forever!!
Check out this short and sweet video from
our new show TestTube 101!